why the Jeffrey Epstein case inspires so
many conspiracy theories Anna North at
Fox comm the question folks is if you
tried could you be this stupid if you
put effort into it if you dedicated
yourself if you trained your mind could
you be this daft
to write an article that is basically
pondering why the Jeffrey Epstein case
inspires so many conspiracy theories why
why why so many unanswered questions
it's a relatively simple thing a man who
was running an international human
trafficking ring
who was close friends with politicians
the CEOs of major corporations prime
ministers a man who had been convicted
of molesting underage girls and given a
sweetheart deal because and I quote
Alexander Acosta Trump's labor secretary
said he quote belonged to intelligence
was given a sweetheart deal where he
served around a year in like a minimum
security federal prison and left every
day to go to work and part of that deal
was that he wouldn't have to inform on
his co-conspirators that man who was
then reread a supposedly cooperating
with prosecutors charged with several
counts of sex trafficking was going to
go to trial and potentially inform on
his co-conspirators because there was no
get-out-of-jail-free card this time a
man who tried to kill himself a few
weeks ago in one of them
secure detention centers in America the
Metropolitan Correctional Facility where
they held El Chapo when they've held
terrorists I think Zacharias Masseria
could be wrong that guy who was on
suicide watch was taken off suicide
watch his roommate was moved out of his
room and a few hours later he hung
himself in said facility and now there
will be no trial and there will be no
open court why would a case like that
all these internet loonies all these
tinfoil hat wearing conspiracy theorists
sees redditors these these marginalized
creatures that just have to make
everything into one big [__]
conspiracy why would this set why set
them off
you better be asking the question why
perfectly rational reasonable people who
had been asleep who had been [__]
asleep and I mean asleep watching The
Bachelor asleep are starting to wake up
now and they're starting to go ahh like
they might not be full on you know
they're not storm in area 51 but they're
even going you know what wait a minute
something's wrong here